foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody CK Coleman what it
is we've got the rest of our team in the
studio as well coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about her boxes
and boxes and boxes of stuff we also
have an outstanding lightning round
segment a live stream question and a
listener tip for you you can check out
the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 374 where we answer four times
the questions and we dive deep into
several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists or click
the link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because say with
me yo
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers if you have a question or call
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Jenna my name is
Jenna and I'm a patreon subscriber from
Davenport Iowa my husband and I moved to
the house we live in about 10 years ago
and multiple boxes and plastic storage
bins have lived in a closet under our
stairs untouched since we moved in last
weekend I eliminated about five large
boxes worth of items unfortunately there
are two large plastic bins that remain
of my own personal sentimental items
these items are from my childhood many
pictures
personalized graffiti gear books even my
personalized sweatshirt and coat from
fifth grade and yes it still fits
many of the pictures and memories from
school during these younger years
involve people who meant the world to me
then but we've since grown distant or
have maybe had a falling out so they
mean nothing to me now
I would say I love most of the memories
these items trigger but have no
connection to these things
I consider some items to be Untouchables
these are things having to do with my
sister who died in 2008. I don't want to
let go of these things because they
bring me Comfort when I see the things
or think of the items I don't foresee
ever letting go of those things
and that brings me back to the fact that
I still have many things living in boxes
that aren't bringing value to my
everyday life
the items I can't bring myself to
release feel like a heavy weight and I
want to know how to either be okay
letting go or to be okay to continue to
store these bins in the closet
Jenna I definitely identify with your
question here when I first stumbled into
minimalism was before I even stumbled
into minimalism Ryan can recall because
he helped me through this I was dealing
with my mom's stuff
and a lot of boxes of sentimental stuff
and of course
at some period of time everything starts
to become sentimental because we assign
some sort of value or meaning to it or
especially what happens she uses this
word that I used as well
Untouchable
I won't even question as to whether or
not I can let go of this which is
another way of saying I can't let go of
this I know I am unable to let go and
I've been Paralyzed by that feeling as
well you look around and there are so
many boxes of stuff
and you're so paralyzed you can't let go
of any of you don't know where to start
right and yet you've already started you
acknowledged Something Beautiful
there were five boxes that you let go of
yeah beautiful and now you've got two
more boxes two bins
where you're wondering could I get rid
of these or actually what sounds like
you're wondering is I'm supposed to get
rid of these in order to feel happiness
well as you know from last week's
episode with Kapil Gupta we're certainly
not going to prescribe
that you should get rid of these bends
because I don't know whether or not that
will make you happier
I know that not being attached to them
will make you Freer
but you don't have to
let go of the Box in order to let go of
the attachment but I can tell you this
clinging
prevents us from moving on hmm and
you brought up that the memories
that those things trigger and I love
that you said that
the things trigger the memories the
photos trigger the memories but you've
already recognized you've let go of the
memories being in the things that's a
giant step in letting go
because it's not
something you did it's something you
understood you understood fundamentally
that my memories my sentiment
my relatives that have passed on are not
in those things and so yes practically
there are some things you can do it you
may have already done you can take
pictures of the things that are
bothering you if they are indeed
bothering you if they're getting in the
way then they're cluttered right
we're not telling you to get rid of
anything on this podcast but understand
that if something's getting in the way
of living a meaningful life it's getting
in the way of your joy if it's causing
some sort of discontent and obvious it
is that's why you're calling in then it
is some sort of clutter whether it's
physical clutter or mental clutter it's
spiritual clutter whatever it might be
it's some sort of clutter for you of
course you can also do a scanning party
we have that in our minimalist rule book
which you can download for free at the
minimalists.com one of the things you
can do is have a scanning party with any
of the photos you don't have to get rid
of the memory triggers you can actually
hold on to the things that trigger the
memories the irony of that though is I
very rarely go back and visit the things
a couple weeks ago Ryan we did a
year-end wrap up when Danny wasn't here
we
have a
Polo tour every week we go into
someone's home and in fact today we're
going into Ryan's home on the private
podcast and we're gonna take a look at
his home we left our homes and we went
back in time to 2011 our very first tour
a year into the minimalists before we
even knew TK before we knew Alabama
before we knew Jordan before we knew
Danny or Emma or social justice or we
knew podcast Sean but he wasn't podcast
Sean then and even when we met Professor
Sean on that tour and we had some photos
from that tour
I went back it's the first time we've
gone look at those things in 10 years
Ryan yeah
and it's okay to go back and have access
to them but I don't need to fill my
house with those photos they can be on a
hard drive or in a cloud somewhere and
if I feel compelled to go back and look
great I will but I'm not going to burden
myself by needing to always go back and
look at them I have access to them which
gives me the peace of mind and that
peace of mind it helps me let go yeah
that's a pretty big deal too especially
because these are just things you want
to look at and they're not things that
you need to use and one of the things I
heard is
they mean nothing to me I also heard it
feels heavy
and the value is that they trigger these
memories and if that's the primary value
you said they trigger these memories
that are important to you when you see
them or when you look at them then maybe
there's a possibility for you to capture
them digitally so that you can see them
and look at them whenever you want but
without having to carry around that
heavy weight because it seems that the
value they provide is primarily what
you've identified the memories that they
invoke so if you can capture that that
capacity to invoke those memories
you're you're good to go yeah oh Jenna
um well it's always hard to say goodbye
to our things
um I guess the more you let go the the
kind of the easier it gets but I mean
even now like you know when Mariah and I
do the the minimalist game or whatever
like it's there's a little bit of
um a little bit of resistance I have to
get through and it's even harder and
Jenna's situation where I mean some of
these things were her sisters and
letting go of her sister's things
um I could see where she would feel
almost like
um
she is uh disrespecting her sister in a
way like that's something that I know I
would probably struggle with if I was
Jenna so I think it's just you know it's
important to understand
like what are these things truly doing
for you because the act of holding on to
your sister's things doesn't make you
love your sister anymore or less or miss
her anymore or less but
um it sounds like the story that you're
kind of telling yourself is is making it
uh one way or the other man
um she's looking for permission to let
go or to hold on Jen I give you
permission to do either you know yeah or
do both yeah because here's what I found
when I started letting go on mom's stuff
I got more value from the few items that
I held on to now I held on to those
things Loosely and nothing was
Untouchable even now I have one
remaining thing of my mom's stuff it's
this hat box which doesn't really match
my aesthetic and my home and it takes up
one shelf and for me that is my
Untouchable thing but I'm willing to
touch it I'm willing to let it go
because if I'm not willing to do that
then I'm clinging and I'm not able to
move on if I am indeed clinging you
mentioned resistance Ryan and I wanted
to touch on that because I think that's
such an important point
whenever I feel resistance
it's generally the path that I want to
take
I got into the ice bath this morning
around 4 30 5 a.m it was early and the
stars were out it was cold and I do this
every morning in fact I often get in the
ice bath two times or three times
yesterday
and every time there is some bit of
resistance sometimes it's a twinge like
I barely feel the resistance other times
it's like oh how am I possibly going to
get into a tub full of ice water
and yet as soon as I feel the resistance
I know that is the direction in which I
want to travel because that's where the
freedom is it's letting go of the
resistance someone might call it pushing
through the resistance like Stephen
pressfield But ultimately it's seeing
that resistance for what it is it's
seeing a weakness in myself that I'm
able to overcome as soon as I witness
that resistance I'm able to go right
through it I'm always glad that I moved
through that resistance
man you brought up the photos we pulled
up
kind of going back 10 years 12 years
whatever it was
um that was awesome like that was really
cool like to go back and
um have all of those those pictures kind
of trigger this these memories of you
know when things were way more simple I
don't I think I said this on the podcast
uh it wasn't easy but it was definitely
more simple back then and
um yeah I mean it's I love taking down a
trip down memory lane
um yeah there's nothing wrong with
there's nothing wrong with uh wanting to
trigger those memories I just I feel
like we just often put these rules in
place that say well I can't go down
memory lane unless I blank
and uh Jenna you might be able to rework
whatever that boundary is that you're
setting up for yourself but you know I
think Josh said it earlier these things
are weighing you down I mean if they're
if they're weighing you down then there
is probably something that you might
benefit from uh from from letting go of
some of these things that are weighing
you down but I just want to reiterate
you have our permission to do whatever
you want to do like we're not here to
tell you what to do
you know also letting go for you doesn't
have to mean letting go for someone else
letting go for someone else and so there
might be ways of Letting Go that don't
require you throwing them out and it's
sometimes easier to let go when we know
that there's someone else that can find
Value out of it so maybe consider that
as a possibility I don't know all the
details of your situation but if there's
someone else in the family for whom
those things would not be clutter who
might find Value in them
then that could be a viable alternative
path
you know I'm going to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains Ryan
and I wrote this toward the beginning of
our journey back in 2012 was when we
were at the first draft so right around
the time of that first tour at the end
of that first tours when we started it
and I think you'll find immense value in
this because it was a process of
well it was really a book about how we
ceased the clinging not how we let go
but all the things we stopped clinging
to in order to move forward
you got this Jenna we'll send you a copy
of the uh audiobook version if you like
our podcast I think you'll like that or
if you want the ebook or the book book
version we'd be happy to send those to
you as well Ryan what time is it oh you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
questions from Tick Tock because we're
cool we got a tick tock account
yes indeed you can follow the minimalist
on Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and
Twitter at the minimalists now during
the lightning round this is where we
each have 60 seconds to answer your
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like looks like cash on desk has a
question for us in Alabama your 30 30
rule sounds dumb to be honest I know
it's a mental trick but can't we just
learn to be disciplined
we say a lot of dumb stuff Josh
[Laughter]
here's what I'll say yes the 30 30 rule
is dumb every rule is dumb
the reason that we set up these
boundaries is because of our own
dumbness our own oversights our own
inability to understand how to maneuver
without boundaries and so yeah if you
think it's dumb I mean you already have
the discipline to not spend then you
don't need a boundary like this you're
already living within your boundaries
right here's something pithy for you
though the solution is the problem the
problem
is the solution
and so this is not a solution for you
this is merely a boundary it's not going
to make you
be a better person it's not going to
make you consume less what it does is it
staves off impulse and if you're
burdened by impulse then this boundaries
for you
all right give me 60 Seconds
Professor Sean um my fifth answer is
this discipline is found within the
boundaries so another way to look at
this is
um discipline doesn't exist without
boundaries and yet a lot of the rules
that we make up are kind of silly or
maybe it's uh uh I don't know Petty or
however you want to look at it but the
rules that you make up is what's going
to create that discipline you cannot
have the discipline unless you set up
some boundaries for yourself
all right let me get that 60 second shot
clock here we go what's useful for me
might be terrible for wheat when
analyzing assessing applying advice
there are two common extremes the first
extreme is to say hey here's something
that was really helpful in my life
therefore it is a universal prescription
that applies to everyone else's life
ever since I started getting up at five
o'clock in the morning my health is
improved my finances have improved I've
made five times as for many friends in
the past five months as I did in the
past five years and you ought to do it
too I don't know anything about you but
Nuance be damn you ought to do what I do
because it worked for me the Other
Extreme is to say look I don't need any
accountability partner to motivate
myself well that's a silly idea why
would you suggest that to anyone I don't
need a coach or a book to help me I just
motivate myself to do it why would you
suggest it anyone else hey look some
people find things useful even when they
are useless to you so the middle way is
to say what's useful to me might not be
useful to we what's useful to we might
not be useful for me and there's no need
to label it Dom or anything else in
between hmm
he shot it right through the buzzer I
think it counted we're gonna have to
look at the replay well you know I had
30 seconds left over so you lent it to
him that's right I will say one thing
about discipline I haven't needed
discipline to do the most profound and
most compelling things in my life yes
there is resistance there but discipline
wasn't required there was an
understanding that if I push through the
resistance then
whatever is waiting for me on the other
side is much more rewarding to me than
avoiding the resistance will be let's
check in with our patreon live stream in
a moment but first real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
because the world needs another podcast
[Music]
Ryan and I we started the side project
with our friends Carl and Alberto back
in 2016. it's called minimalism life
and you can find it at minimalism.com
that's right minimalism.com you can also
follow it on Twitter at minimalism on
Tick Tock at minimalism
we're still trying to get that
minimalism for Instagram we're working
on that but uh we have at minimalism
life over there as well but we just
started a podcast called minimalism life
and it's just once a month and it's
about three minutes speaking of
minimalism
so if you want to subscribe to you can
find it wherever podcasts are casted
wherever pods are casted
Spotify Apple
Etc we just released the first few
episodes on Christmas day as a nice
little bonus so you can find the first I
don't know four or five episodes out
there at this point they're like three
minutes long a little essay and some
commentary on the essay and and not too
long I'll ask TK and Ryan and maybe Carl
and Professor Sean and a few others to
join on this journey short little
bite-sized insights about minimalist
well-being minimalist travel minimalist
design you can find that we'll put a
link to the minimalism Life podcast
which comes out once a month for the
beginning of the month we think you'll
enjoy it let's check in with our patreon
live stream
Alabama I know we're not actually live
streaming this episode but you collected
a question from a previous live stream
what do you got for us I did this is a
question from Nina she asks how do you
guys find time to film your podcast
while in the same location don't you all
live in different cities sort of so we
actually come in here on Tuesdays at 10
A.M to do the live stream and record a
podcast and often spend an entire day
yes all three of us live in different
counties and so technically different
cities I'm up in Ventura County Ryan's
here in Los Angeles County TK is down in
Orange County the OG from the OC yeah
you know me
and yet we come together once or twice a
week and then we do what the whole world
has been doing for a few years now we
work remotely the other times and we do
the same thing with our team we don't
force someone to work a nine to five and
even if you've completed your task you
must stay here until the Bell Rings no
you do what you you need to do in order
to get the job done
and that's what we do we come in here
once or twice a week relatively
regularly make a long drive get up early
but it's totally worth it I don't feel
like I have to do this I feel like I get
to do it yeah me neither I I don't feel
like I have to do it
I got a gun underneath the desk
right it's like you've got 45 seconds
and it was it was really about doing
what's best for you
tell them how much you like it or else
so once you drive down here like hour 30
minutes something like that it depends
so I left this morning around 5 30 and I
got here in an hour and a half yeah and
um sometimes though if I'll leave the
wrong time like we were here in the
studio on Sunday of all times last week
and
the drive home was over three hours
because there was a huge thing that was
tipped over on the 101 and
um so I just make room for that and I
will use that time still I would prefer
not to have the long drive however
because I do have it
um I just use it I make phone calls yeah
I listen to audiobooks or podcasts or
listen to music I decompress I'll do Wim
Hof breathing but not too much of it
because I don't want to pass out behind
the wheel but I used that time that's
been given to me because it doesn't feel
like a burden we used to do it all the
time remember Ryan used to drive from
Piqua Ohio to Cincinnati oh my goodness
man he lived in Piqua that's like
driving
I don't know from New York City to La
basically yeah pretty much no I uh I
would even go down to like
um Florence Kentucky
so I mean it was even further no I mean
yeah with the long commutes there's
always like something you can kind of do
with the podcast or audio books so how
long is it does it take you to get here
from
uh on average an hour and a half is it
okay if I leave early enough it can be
like a solid hour if I leave late enough
it can be two hours yeah all depends on
Trump and L.A is so funny that way it's
like you might leave and it says oh
you'll be there in 25 minutes and then
an accident happens and then yeah all of
a sudden it's three hours when I was a
dog sitter I walked an hour and a half
there and then an hour and a half back
every day for work uphill both ways
from Alabama I know we had one other
patreon question we typically do a live
stream every
Tuesday at 10 A.M so we gathered this
we're late on this because it was I
believe a Christmas gift question but
let's apply it more broadly to gifts in
general because we're faced with this
all year right what's right around the
corner now Valentine's Day and after
that Ryan always gets me something for
Flag Day
that's right this is a question from
Meredith and she said every year I beg
my family not to give me any gifts and
every year they refuse to respect my
wishes this year my husband and I moved
to a new house and I've tried to explain
to them that we're trying to downsize it
hurts my feelings that they refuse to
listen to me and respect my wishes this
sounds like such a first world problem I
know but I don't want a dread
celebrations because of things like this
any suggestions what if I went to your
living room and just dumped a big pile
of trash in there and I was like here
you go
Merry Christmas oh like what would you I
mean it's easy to look at that and say
well if it was trash I would you know
I'd get it out of my house as soon as
possible but we're talking about traffic
we are talking about trash it looks a
little bit different or if I you know
took
um some end tables and threw them in
your front lawn here you go
here's some end tables for you I mean
are you just gonna leave them there be
because I gave them to you like no it's
it's something that um doesn't serve a
purpose it doesn't bring you Joy you
didn't ask for it you're gonna get rid
of it
um it is a little bit more difficult
when someone gives you something but
you know if someone is disrespecting
your boundaries if they're going out of
their way to not support you
um I guess
you don't have to go out of your way to
support the decisions that they're
making for you you are allowed to say no
you're allowed to say no no is a
complete sentence on its own if someone
wants to give you a gift and you don't
want that gift you don't have to be mean
about it you can show compassion and
still say no thank you no I'm not going
to accept that no I'm not going to bring
it into my life especially if you've
already communicated the fact that I
don't want any excess stuff this isn't a
judgment unto you I don't have to
explain myself I'm simply going to say
no no I don't want that gift no I don't
want that necktie no I don't want those
cufflinks no I don't want that purse no
I don't want that gift card no I don't
want the things you want to Heap on to
me and it's not a judgment of you it is
simply understanding what adds value to
my life you're understanding that you
have enough now I'll say one other thing
you might be telling them you don't want
it but they may not may not be hearing
you and so is there some other way that
you can get them to hear you without
being rude without being mean without
being unkind is there a way to help them
understand that what they're doing
is not adding value to your life at all
hmm
yeah people don't respond to the
boundaries you promise but to the
boundaries that you deliver and the way
you deliver on a boundary isn't by
talking about it so that people can hear
it but by making your boundary felt and
as as unfair and harsh As It Seems
when we express dissatisfaction that's
just not as moving as when we flat out
refuse to accept something and you could
do that in a couple of ways you can say
no one refused to accept it or you can
say hey look if you give that to me I've
already told you how I feel I'm gonna
sell it or I'm gonna give it away if you
think you're going to be angry about
that you should factor that into your
decision now and then you've got to make
good on it you've either got to deliver
a heart no or you've got to let them
know what you're going to do with it and
then do that thing with it because as
Ryan said once they give it to you it's
yours and you get to do with it whatever
you please and that means Give It Away
sell it whatever it may be yeah yeah my
my grandma my oma gave me that
paperweight she's like here you go
here's you're you're a you're an author
here's a paperweight because I must just
have papers everywhere Ryan I got you a
metaphor right
[Laughter]
very kindly said
um wow thanks for thinking of me that
really means a lot this is a beautiful
paperweight you know what I don't really
have a spot for this but if if you would
like I I can find it a really good home
if you want and she was like oh could
you do that I'm like yeah I'd be happy
to find it a good home so I found it a
good home now things that you have in
your house right now that people gave
you that you don't want
the one thing that I would recommend or
let me just say what I would do if I was
in your situation
I would call up the person who gave me
that thing and I'd say hey you know what
you gave me this thing however many
years weeks whatever months ago
um it's a really beautiful thing
I don't have room for it anymore so I
was thinking about donating it or I was
thinking about selling it but I wanted
to call you first to see if you wanted
to do something else with it and if not
then I will find it a better home but I
wanted to to give the courtesy of
calling you uh to see um you know what
you would think would be the most
appropriate way for me to get rid of
this I love that
I'm not saying no to you
I'm saying no to this thing because I
simply don't have the space for it
and that's it
how can you argue with that yes you do
have the space yeah no I simply don't
have the space for it would you be
willing
to withhold the gift giving
this birthday this Valentine's Day the
sweetest day this flag day
we should start a shop call
unwantedgifts.com all the people that
are receiving these unwanted gifts they
send them to us and we just sell them
online for them and we can just donate
the money to charity
unwantedgifts.com I don't own the domain
well someone's gonna go buy it now yeah
hopefully we can send them the gifts all
right before we get to our listener tips
today coming up on the maximal episode
if you're listening to the public
episode here the minimal episode we have
a million more questions from callers
social media and the live stream a
private minimalist home tour we're gonna
walk into Ryan's house and uh man do I
have to talk to you about this house
Ryan
I like it hey they don't call me the
messy minimalist for nothing we do a
weekly home tour every week where we
invite you into our homes and you can
scrutinize it with us we also have our
impulse purchases segment this might be
my favorite impulse purchase segment you
were watching the video with me
beforehand Ryan oh this described me I
think as a teenager and I think a lot of
you will find Value in this one plus of
course TK's tweet of the week we've got
an outstanding added value segment for
you as well and much much more of less
and if you want to hear all that check
out the minimalists private podcast
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description I'm Alabama what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
hi my name is Hannah and I'm from LA and
I wanted to leave a comment for
listeners based on your addiction
episode
my husband and I have been dealing with
addiction issues in our families and
relationships for many years and we've
finally found an approach that has
aligned well with minimalism and all the
things we've learned from Josh and Ryan
so there's a recovery program called
smart recovery for addicts and loved
ones as well as a book for loved ones
called Beyond addiction how science and
kindness can help people change both
encourage a real methodology steeped in
science that allowed us to simplify
these really intimidating issues we
wanted to share what we found in hopes
that it will help other minimalists
simplify the complexity of addiction
issues in their life all right y'all
that is our minimal episode for today
we'll see you on patreon for the full
two hour maximal edition of episode 374.
if you leave here today with just one
message
might it be this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you